thank you ted finley acura who is
sponsoring this next segment is always
helping our community this month finley
acura would like to put the spotlight on
one special cause take a look
[Music]
this is the acura tlx type s 0 to 60 is
5.1 seconds
355 horsepower but today we're not here
to talk about this incredible car no no
we're here to talk about an incredible
cause my name is travis aguilar sales
manager here at findlay acura we're very
proud to be partnered with project 150.
hi i'm kelly cristo with project 150.
project 150 provides basic necessities
to homeless displaced and disadvantaged
high school students here in southern
nevada we provide food clothing hygiene
products and school supplies year round
travis why did you decide to start
working with project 150 well after
learning about what they're doing in the
community and what they're being such a
great need we wanted to bring awareness
to their costs and try and help support
them in our community in any way that we
can
so we thought we'd reach out here to you
guys and help bring some awareness kelly
who do you guys serve
we serve any of the homeless displaced
and disadvantaged high school students
here in southern nevada how do you get
connected with with these homeless teams
so we partner directly with all 75 high
schools here in southern nevada we work
with the counselors the principals and
the teachers they usually have the first
interaction with the student and they
refer them to us for our services is
there is there some kind of statistic or
something that just might surprise us
when we tell people what you guys do and
you have that one statistic when you
tell people they just can't believe it
do you have one like that um how about
that there's about six thousand homeless
high school students right here in
southern nevada i mean it's crazy isn't
it it's a number that's six thousand too
high is what the number is absolutely
what are some of the services you guys
provide so we provide clothing uh school
supplies hygiene food
we deliver directly to the schools every
week so
we do it so that we can encourage the
students to stay in school get their
high school diploma and then move on to
college so we also offer college
scholarships so they stay right here in
vegas graduate and then hopefully build
a really successful future how has
things been over the past year with the
pandemic how are things been for you
guys so it's been up and down with great
need so our services were in high demand
we were considered an essential business
handing out food like crazy
to people that maybe have never even
used a food pantry or needed our
services in the past so numbers
skyrocketed we are leveling off now so
things are starting to get back to
normal and we are now back open for
students to come use betty's boutique oh
and now someone's watching right now how
can we help you have any big events
coming up we do we have our annual fall
fundraiser coming up october 9th and
people can purchase tickets at
project150.org
we also have ways that the community can
get involved by donating clothing for
betty's boutique hygiene items food
drives all over town so there's tons of
ways to get involved with us just
everything on project150.org i love it
you're doing great things kelly thank
you so much you always appreciate uh
chatting with you and travis finley
actor i thank you guys for everything
you do in las vegas thank you
thank you findlay acura for sponsoring
this segment they're located on 315 auto
mall drive in henderson just give them a
call at 702-982-4
or find them online at
findlayacura.com las vegas